Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan, and
today I'm revealing 14 hidden easter eggs,
adorable call-backs to the first movie, and
cameos you missed in To All The Boys: P.S.
I Still Love You.
Plus, I'll be explaining the secret end-credits
teaser that sets up the third and final movie
in the trilogy.
Spoilers ahead if you haven't seen the film
yet.
"Let's do this."
Remember how Lara Jean fell on her back in
a faint when Peter spoke to her about the
love letter she wrote him in the first movie?
Well, it seems like LJ has something of a
habit of falling down during meet-cutes as
she lands flat on her back once again when
she runs into John Ambrose for the first time
in the sequel.
Though this time it's a bowl of candy that
sends her crashing to the ground!
In those two moments, we see LJ literally
falling for Peter and John.
And it seems pretty fitting that Lara Jean's
meet-cute with John mirrors her meet-cute
with Peter given that they all end up in a
love triangle together.
When Lara Jean wins the snow globe at the
fun fair with Peter, she asks him to watch
as she tips it upside down and then back again,
showering the couple inside the globe with
snow.
What LJ doesn't realise is that this foreshadows
how her world will be turned upside down by
John Ambrose later in the movie.
Like the snow globe couple, she ends up kissing
John in the snow.
"It's a funny thing, this relationship stuff.
One moment, things are upside down, but then,
like magic, there's glitter everywhere.
And once it all settles, you're right back
in the fairy tale again."
As LJ unwittingly predicted, when her kiss
with John Ambrose didn't feel right, Peter
arrived to bring the glitter back and they
both end up with another sort of fairy tale
ending.
And talking of globes, there's an enormous
one at the aquarium which looks flipped upside
down compared to the position we're often
used to seeing it in.
This shot comes just before Lara Jean and
Peter break up officially and reflects their
emotional state of feeling upside down.
When Lara Jean and friends get together in
their old treehouse haunt, there are numerous
memories from their childhood pinned on the
walls behind them.
One of particular note is a drawing that's
reminiscent of a Harry Potter sorting hat,
a link back to how LJ and John Ambrose used
to read Harry Potter together in the treehouse.
"You said you were House Hufflepuff, and that
was my house, too, and I thought maybe that
was a sign that we were meant to be."
There's also a couple of pictures of a dog
in the treehouse, which could be Chris's rescue
pup she mentioned earlier in the movie or
it could be a nod to the novels where Kitty
had a dog named Jamie Fox-Pickle.
There was already a hat-tip to that family
dog from the book in the first movie when
Kitty asked her father,
"Can we have a dog now?"
"No, but that's a nice try."
If you're a fan of the To All The Boys book
trilogy, you were likely delighted to see
author Jenny Han pop up in the first movie
as a chaperone at Lucas and Lara Jean's school
dance.
This time she makes an appearance during the
Valentine's Day scene in the school cafeteria.
Just before the acapella group appears on
screen serenading a fellow student, you can
spot Jenny comforting a crying, likely lovelorn,
teenage girl.
As a producer on the To All The Boys movies,
Han has also been a major influence on Lara
Jean's on-screen style, collaborating closely
with the franchise's costume department.
And Jenny isn't the only member of the Han
family to show up on screen in P.S.
I Still Love You.
In the Korean New Year scene, you can see
her real-life parents playing Lara Jean's
grandparents.
In fact, Han told the LA Times that she and
her mother even taught Lana Condor, Anna Cathcart,
who plays Kitty, and John Corbett, who plays
their dad, 'how to properly greet their relatives'
for the scene.
P.S.
I Still Love You continues in the first film's
tradition of referencing 80s coming-of-age
movies by kicking off with Lara Jean energetically
dancing to "Then He Kissed Me" by The Crystals
in a tribute to the 1987 feature Adventures
in Babysitting.
In fact, LJ actually recreates many of the
key moments from the opening scene of that
film, such as miming to the song in front
of her mirror;
spinning across the room;
singing "I love you" to a portrait of her
boyfriend before kissing it;
using her curtains to make a bride's veil;
and then finally falling back on the bed and
tipping her head to face the camera.
Kitty, of course, jolts Lara Jean back to
life with a sharp reminder that:
"Seriously, Lara Jean?
Now is not the time to be fantasizing about
living in an '80s movie."
And that moment itself is a funny call-back
to how the 80s were such an important cultural
reference for LJ in the first film.
For example, when they formulated their fake
relationship rules, Lara Jean used the opening
scene of the 1984 movie Sixteen Candles as
the basis for the rule that Peter was allowed
to put his hand in her back pocket.
It seems perfectly fitting that a franchise
based on a set of much-loved novels should
do its bit to celebrate the joy of reading.
In the school corridor when LJ and Peter are
discussing John Ambrose's letter, look carefully
at the background and there are a couple of
display boards with the words "Books Can Take
You Anywhere"
and "Reading Gives You Wings" together with
a beautiful 3D display of butterflies bursting
out of a pair of books.
When Lara Jean uses an ice cream sandwich
to demonstrate to Lucas just how much she
overthinks her relationship with Peter, it's
an amusing moment.
"Has Peter shared an ice cream sandwich with
someone before?
Maybe it's me.
Maybe I'm the one who wants to do more than
just share an ice cream sandwich."
But the choice of this particular snack is
also a deliberate easter egg to Jenny Han's
novel.
In the book, when the group get together at
the treehouse, LJ packs a bag full of ice-cream
sandwiches and Cheez Doodles, rather than
the cupcakes she bakes and pizza John Ambrose
brings in the movie.
And just like in the book where Peter takes
the last ice-cream sandwich, in the movie
he also nabs the last slice of pizza.
"Is he... is he still like he was in middle
school?"
"What does that mean?"
"At parties and stuff, he would always take
the last slice of pizza.
And then whenever you tried to call him out
on it, he'd be like, 'I'm an athlete.'"
When Lara Jean reads her original letter to
John Ambrose, memories of the Halloween party
she dressed up for come flooding back.
"I felt so lame.
Like I didn't fit in.
And then, you walked in as a deviled egg.
And I realized...
maybe I'm lame in a cool way."
Of course, the blue beret that young LJ wears
is part of her French toast costume, but it's
also a lovely shout-out to the novel in which
Lara Jean has what she describes as a "charming
and jaunty beret collection".
When Peter first finds out he's in a potential
love triangle with LJ and John Ambrose, the
moment perfectly reflects their situation.
Not only are he and LJ in a biology class
at the time, but the teacher is talking about
how octopuses have three hearts!
And, like in their love triangle, one of those
octopus hearts is about to get broken by Lara
Jean who dissects it in front of a squeamish
Peter, foreshadowing their break-up later
in the film.
But that's not the only bit of foreshadowing
in this classroom scene because there's also
a hint at the location where Peter and LJ's
relationship will come to an end:
"The octopus is a mollusc and we will get
to see one of those during next week's visit
to the Portland Aquarium."
Oh, and if you think back to the first film,
it was also in front of a fish tank at a party
that Gen and her friend nosily quizzed LJ
about her new relationship with Peter.
"What do you wanna know?"
"Everything.
When?
How?
How far?
H on B?
H up and down on P?"
And it was in the same spot that Lara Jean
and Peter took selfies to make Gen jealous
of their fake relationship.
The first movie had a mid-credits scene that
teased the return of John Ambrose in the sequel.
And To All The Boys 2 also has a little end-credits
tease for the third movie though it's very
well hidden.
The song that plays right at the end of the
credits is called Better By Myself.
It's by the band Hey Violet who've said it's
about 'realizing that sometimes it's better
to be on your own and learn how to love yourself
before you try to love anyone else or be with
someone that doesn't put in the effort you
need them to.'
If you've read Jenny's Han's novels, then
you'll know that Always And Forever, Lara
Jean, which is the final book in the trilogy,
focuses on the complications that arise when
LJ and Peter look to life after high school
and their plans for college.
The end-credits song in this movie doesn't
necessarily mean LJ and Peter will break up
for good, but it does hint that LJ may spend
some time by herself working out what's best
for her in the long run.
"I am trying to make sure you know how to
rev your own engine.
Make sure you know how to look after you!"
"Yeah, okay, I get it.
I get it."
The cast and crew already filmed To All The
Boys 3 straight after P.S.
I Still Love You, and Lana Condor has said
its 'definitely the [franchise's] most mature
movie'.
And in an interview with Entertainment Tonight,
she also revealed that in the third film,
"[LJ] really starts to make decisions for
herself that might be unpopular but at the
end of the day, as a young woman, you have
to protect your own heart and make the decisions
that are truly right for you regardless of
the other people around you."
On the separate note as to whether John Ambrose
will ever make a reappearance in Lara Jean's
life, actor Jordan Fisher is keeping his lips
sealed.
However, Fisher, Anna Cathcart, Lana Condor,
and even Noah Centineo have all said that
they think that Peter is great for LJ's younger
years, while John is an endgame boyfriend
or husband.
There's certainly plenty of debate among fans
over whether Peter or John is the better partner
for Lara Jean, and I did a full breakdown
and discussion about whether LJ made the right
decision in my Ending Explained video.
Tap the screen here or follow the link in
the video description to watch that.
Now, did you spot any other easter eggs in
the sequel?
And what do you want to see happen in the
final film?
Let me know in the comments below!
If you enjoyed this, be sure to subscribe
for all my new videos including Netflix's
Sabrina, You, Locke and Key, and Stranger
Things.
Tap left for my next video or tap right for
another video you're sure to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!